Democrats are thirsty for attention
literally news Squad Congressman Greg
Kazar getting mocked after holding a
thirst and hunger strike on the steps of
the Capitol that only lasted a
breathtaking eight hours he was
protesting a recent Texas law signed by
Governor Greg Abbott the Democrats say
banned required water breaks of
construction sites but Abbott has thrown
cold water on that he says the bill will
quote not inhibit people from taking
water breaks and there's another climate
change virtue signaler who is trying to
demonize Republicans
I don't know anybody who honestly
believes climate change is not a serious
problem I've never seen it as hot as it
is now for as long as it's been we
provided a record 50 billion dollars for
climate resiliency but our Maggie
extremist Congress are trying to undo
all this progress
not a single one of them not a single
Republican voted voted for the inflation
reduction acts but had all this money in
it for climate
and check out this climate hysteria CNN
can't make up their minds on whether
we're going to die from global warming
soon or in 70 years
there is new science about a big uh
circulation system in the Atlantic known
as the amok this is that shuts down it's
sort of an apocalyptic scenario we've
seen in movies like the day after
tomorrow there is some debate as to when
that Tipping Point Could Happen a new
paper has it as early as 2025 but as
late as 20 90.
all right yeah Jesse I'll start with you
with the guy who was who is
the guy who was fasting for eight hours
and there were people all over and
making sure that he was going to survive
don't we sleep for eight hours without
drinking water in solidarity last night
I took a thirst and hunger break from 11
PM to 7 A.M and I got to tell you I am
exhausted I've never had I mean it
actually happens every single night
judge but
it was really hot out I just looked into
this there is no law that Abbott's
signing that's Banning water breaks
exactly it reminds me of don't say gay
it reminds me of the the the slavery
controversy it's one of these made-up
controversies that the entire left-wing
media runs with and everybody in Texas
is still like yes Logan Paul and spring
like what are you talking about yeah the
amazing thing is this guy is in
Washington he's not even in Texas okay
all right Sandra the annual uh Heat Wave
index for 48 states was substantially
higher in the late 1930s than any point
in recent years in some years in the
1930s it was four times greater or even
more so heat waves in the summer are
relatively normal yeah um I'm not taking
away from the fact that it it's hot out
there there's no doubt you shouldn't be
going on a water strike eight hours okay
some of the Republican lawmakers that
responded eight whole hours what a hero
I mean you see them like out there with
like the cold cloths on his head
um congratulations on existing between
early lunch and late dinner
kind of absurd
um I I think to Jesse's point I went
through the details of the bill it does
not say anywhere that they're taking
away water breaks doesn't even mention
water at all I mean correct me if I'm
wrong Jessica there's not even water in
the bill
um it apparently this Congressman who's
the latest member of the squad According
to some of the editorial here
um the reference here is he says that
there's no Texas statute specifically
requiring water breaks for employees in
some form Greg Abbott put out a
statement we endorse water breaks our
workers should be taking water who
doesn't allow water breaks where is this
coming from I can't find anything that
says they can't drink water Craig I
don't know
Jessica listen I'll go to you on
National issues climate change ranks 17
out of 21 to Sandra's Point are we not
getting it or the Dem smarter what's
going on here yes to all of that uh no
it climate change is the number one or
number two issue to younger voters who
take this incredibly seriously and just
because it shows up as 17 of 21 doesn't
mean that it matters at all feels like
people can't kind of like go in the
middle or have any Nuance to these
things you don't have to say it's the
most important thing in the world we
know the economy is the most important
issue to voters but we also know that we
should be taking better care of our
climate and that yes if it was that hot
in 1930 it's been a long time between
then and there are people that are
really suffering from this and it's
happening in Republican states and you
see Representatives up talking about it
and taking it really seriously I agree
with you about the water thing I think
what they were trying to go for is that
there should be a law codifying the fact
that you have to give it he also has
apparently signed a bill that would
eliminate heat protection advisories in
Dallas and in Austin which this
Congressman was protesting but there's
something going on like a lot of people
are in prisons they're dying there are
non-air-conditioned prisons in Texas and
people can you believe these murderers
they just
give me a few names and a few stats on
that what yeah
well first of all I I'm always wary when
we linking uh stances to suffering
because there's always we owe the
Republicans are the right or what I
would say Common Sense people are always
portrayed as anti-compassion it's like
how dare you question this
it's hot out there and people are
unhappy it's like yeah yeah but you're
not hell helping matters although this
dude this Greg dude gives a good name to
Greg's uh I tell people when people ask
me if I drink I say I stay away from the
stuff 22 hours a day and uh if a a
cheating husband can now go to their
unhappy spouse and say look I'm
monogamous four times a week you know
aren't I the real hero so I think when
he comes up with this stuff
it's self-absorption right it creates a
shield from reality that's where he is
and reality then becomes a blind spot
especially if you are catering to the
clicks right that that stunt was curated
for the reality of social media so then
when it appears in this in the actual
reality the plain light of day it looks
absolutely hilarious he thinks he's the
Rosa Parks of perspiration right but I
mean uh Jessica you put it at a really
good point in The Green Room actually
for real look at what's on his finger
look what's on his face so Greg is
telling the truth about that
when I saw it so it takes your oxygen
levels and I hadn't seen one since I
took care of my dad as he was dying we
had to keep putting it on and off to
make sure that he didn't dip below a
blood oxygen level where we had to take
him to the hospital so I thought when I
before I had read what was going on I
was like oh my God there's a man dying
on the steps of the Capitol yeah yeah it
was pretty routine yeah dying on the
capital yeah yeah is that reference to
January 6. I
I understand I'm saying the imagery of
it was more intense probably than eight
hours without water well yeah the guys
apparently a hero to some hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else